on behalf of all 30 teams in the nba
it's my honor to be here tonight for
your jersey retirement ceremony dirk and
jessica
uh mark cuban you guys know how to do
jersey retirements here in dallas and in
texas i've been to a bunch of these i've
never seen one like this
let me just say dirk
they love you here in dallas but they
love you all over the world you're a
trendsetter in this league
21 years at one team never been done
before in the league brought this team
a championship
one of the 75 greatest
of all time
an icon throughout the league
somebody who's been a pioneer
for international players so many of the
players on the court tonight grew up
watching you you inspired them you
showed them
international player used to mean
something different in the league before
you came in and people came to
understood it mean championship caliber
it meant great training great
development
it meant
creating culture
what you've done here
and i'd say be on behalf of the league
the fact that you're now back involved
with the dallas mavericks back involved
in the league is a thrill for all of us
so thank you for including me here
tonight and congratulations on your
jersey retirement it's a huge thrill to
be here
i gotta catch my breath
um i don't know where to start
i don't have i don't have that much time
but
let's just see
quick question
we're giving out 10 days you want to
come back
no
you've changed the game
now everybody shoots threes
[Applause]
but the biggest thing you've always been
a champion
day one
and dallas has watched you grown to
become the man you are today
so thank you for approving the trade to
bring me back
to fill my dream and that's to win a
championship
i've taken up all my time
but also this is a sacrifice too so
also i want to thank your family your
beautiful wife jess your beautiful kids
your mom and dad holder right because
this is what it's all about so now it's
their turn to carry the torch and i know
you're going to be a great dad
look forward to some tennis but i but
make sure you you come back and take
that 10 day cube can afford it thanks
and one of the things we do so that all
future mavs fans and all future players
will always know your greatness is
we put your number up in the rafters
but that's not all we do dirk
because i want everybody to see more of
you and because i made you a promise i'm
going to keep my promise
budget was a little bit tight so that's
actual size
no this will be in front of the arena
and the next arena
and the next arena
and it's going to be big
but more than anything else
from myself my family to your family to
holger to all your teammates always to
the nelsons who helped bring you here to
everybody who made all this so special
thank you dirk
we did this not because
this is not because you won us a
championship this is because of who you
are
what you've done and we always want to
recognize greatness
forevermore
[Applause]